[Music]
hallo YouTube just lost my friends this
is guns in here
welcome to my third episode of love and
Tulsa's interprete from the black
perspective after E 4 C 5 Knight to f3
Knight to c6 d4 C captors d4 Knight
captures d4 and the movie 5 in the last
episode we have covered all the
sidelines Knight moves and we come to
the conclusion that they are pretty
harmless to the black camp and even
after the move Knight to be five and a
six if white knight retrieved back to
either C 3 or a 3 then again those
variations doesn't give any sort of
comfortable game for the white camp
so if white has to keep his slight
advantage then he has to play Knight to
d6 Chad and after Bishop captures d6
Queen captures d6 and the move Queen to
f6 we have reached the starting point of
the Lowenthal Sicilian now as for the
introduction there are 6 Queen move
exist and in ascending order we are
going to look each by turn in detail in
this video we are going to concentrate
on the move Queen to d3 which is the
least popular choice by a white camp and
I have a very bad memory with this move
I still remember that when I have
completed my novel sessile interprete I
was so excited and just within the first
game my opponent churn out this move
which gives me ultimate shock as at that
time I didn't even know that this mu
exists eventually I lost the game and
the lesson long that you cannot
underestimate even lesser move played by
the white
looking at this move right now I think
it's not a good choice by white cam and
there are two good reasons number one
this queen is blocking the view of the
LightSquared bishop and the second
important point is in almost all the
lines the break we are looking is defy
and if you look at the Queen location it
can certainly get hit by night to b4
which allow this traumatic push defy so
all in all if you know about few things
then you are completely fine against
this model now the first memory mark you
have to remember is apart from Queen to
d1 if I turn out any other Queen moves
then blacks first move is very obvious
Knight to e7 looking at to support the
default break so accordingly white needs
to stop it and the mainline start with
Knight to c3 however white can also play
the move seafood which unfortunately
never happened in any game and I can see
a good reason about it because it gives
away this juicy square where Black
Knight can jump on it and I have a catch
a model game in the PGN which will give
you a very good idea how comfortable
black play happens against the move c4
well apart from Knight to c3 white can
also try other moves such as g3 or
Bishop to e2 which are kind of slow and
which allows what actually black wants
to do so for example if you open and
continue here with Bishop to e2 trying
to castle on the Kings side well then he
get this ultimate hit defy so all this
lines black achieved what he wants to do
namely defy break after a captures defy
yes indeed you can play the Moon Knight
to be food and regain the pawn back but
I found even a better continuation
starting with Knight to d4
so threat is very simple black wants to
play Bishop to a5 and then deliver a
folk on c2 well white has to stop it so
the natural move over here is Knight to
e3 but even after this black and simply
regain his pawn back with Knight
captures defy and not only the threat
remain as it is but look at Black
Knights
they are wonderfully post on the center
of the world compared to white pcs which
are completely miss coordinated we don't
need to go further as if you put this
position in any professional engine it
like black position quite a lot so it is
pretty clear that white cannot play any
slow moves and he has to play with
Knight to c3 so at first glance it looks
like white has prevented of a thematic
break but guess what
nope we are going to play the move defy
anyways and this is the second important
memory marker remember in Queen to d3
line you will always play the move defy
and sacrifice the bone amazingly enough
it is now white who has to be careful as
he has to know exactly how he is going
to capture on the d5 square for example
white can already go wrong if he
captured with the pawn as after the Moon
Knight to be for not only black is
attacking twice on d5 but white Queen
has to go to the e4 square in order to
save the disaster well one of my own
blitz game continued here with Queen to
d1 so my opponent doesn't realize the
danger and I get immediately winning
position after the following sequence
Bishop to a5 looking at juicy C 2 square
so white has the only defense
Bishop to d3 and after that I calmly
continue with rook to d8 after White's a
three night chapters defy night captors
defy and now Luke kept his defy already
gives of when engaged to the black camp
my opponent decided to get out of the
pain with Queen to e2 but what he missed
is after Bishop captures d3 pawn
captures d3 and the simple and the
trademark mu of the Lowenthal Sicilian
Queen to g6 attacking to spot and white
cannot defend both of them so that means
white has to play Queen to e4 in order
to not only support on c2 but counter
attacking the loose before night okay no
issues black is going to continue with
Quinn to d6 defending the knight and
renewing the threat of Bishop to a5 and
kindly note that if you open and
continue with Bishop to g5 then Epic's
is a very strong to apply well white has
no choice he has to play a three again
attacking the knight and black responds
his force black has to capture back the
pawn with B night after night captors
defy here comes the third important
memory marker do not recapture
immediately but please develop your
light square Bishop with Bishop to a5
the point is after Queen check Bishop to
d7 and the move Queen to e4 we have
developed of a bishop on a very
important square now black is going to
recap to the piece with Knight captures
d5 and after Bishop to c4 and the move
Bishop to c6 not only black is ahead in
peace development but as I have
highlighted here White has a
simple plan to execute namely castle and
then quick fi which gives him a good
attacking position on White King side
okay so it is very obvious that White
has to capture this pawn with his own
night after that we are going to capture
this night with a seven I again white is
in a crossroad and he has to play the
right move namely Queen captures d5
if he continued with he captures defy
then black get the instantly winning
position after this very nation night to
d4 and the threat is very obvious Bishop
to a5 and you can check it by himself
there is no way Y can defend this threat
what of the game in the database
continue with Queen to d1 but after
Queen to g6
black is attacking to soft sports and
unfortunately white cannot defend
put the threat so by force here white
has to capture with the Queen
and for a time being yes indeed white is
upon up but believe it or not this is
exactly black ones and is after the move
Bishop to e6 attacking the Queen Queen
has to go back to d3 as if he goes
anywhere else let's say Queen to C Phi
trying to stop castling black has this
annoying move twin to g6 which is not
easy to dealt with so by force White
Queen has to go back to the d3 and after
that here comes the fourth important
memory marker you have to play Queen to
g6 in order to prevent this light square
bishop development
also Queen to g6 creates some nasty
problems for the white camp for example
one of my game against 2200 rated
opponent continued with Bishop to e3
which looked so natural that white wants
to castle on the Queen side but after
just one night to be full and my
opponent realized that he lost the poon
on a broad daylight so why it has to be
very very careful in the database one of
the game continued with g3 so why plan
is very obvious he wants to play Bishop
to g2 castle on the Kings side and I
remain healthy point up right well nope
it's not that simple as black activity
can create some nasty problems to the
white camp rightly so black continue
with Knight to be for the same old story
attacking to sports and accordingly
right now White has the only defense
quint we to saving both the trends but
black keep pushing wait rook to see it
attacking on c2 one more time
c3 happen in the game but has happened
in many case when one side has very good
piece development tactics immediately
comes into the table I hope you already
see it right yup black deliver this
deciding blow Bishop to c4 attacking the
Queen and it doesn't matter wherever the
Queen goes white is going to lose hold
rook for example if Queen to d2 then we
have Queen captures Evo and the rook on
h1 will hang and accordingly if Quint we
have three then we have light to see to
check this time around we are getting
the rook on the other side of the border
so amazingly enough white has no option
to go on the queenside with Bishop to b2
and after black castle on the Kings side
why it has to castle on the Queen side
so now you can see the benefit of
sacrificing a pawn we get open D and C
file which not only gives hell lot of
attack on the White King but
surprisingly enough in this position
black has a mortar which gives the pawn
back immediately
the first more is very obvious rook F to
d8 attacking the Queen kindly note Queen
has to stay in the safeguard of efore
corn and accordingly Queen to e3 is R
obvious response ok now comes the fifth
memory marker and before I show it to
you kindly pause the video and find out
the amazing resource for the black camp
did you find it let's see I hope you
find this deciding floor boom ha taboo
so not only black has regain his pawn
back but as I have highlighted over here
black has a very simple plan of campaign
that he wants to play Knight to d4 and
then look to see which gives him great
attack on the White King especially if
white doesn't try to trap this bishop
and plays slow moves as I have
highlighted over here but hang on
many of you will ask a simple question
well isn't that a blunder can't white
play the move b3 and trap down this
bishop well yes he can except he will
get a completely lost position
there's a great chance that your
opponent might fall for this as there is
not a single game in the database which
continue in this manner so this is one
of my own invention guys and let's see
what is the problem if white tries to
capture of a piece the problem start by
blacks next energetic reply a5 and what
happens if white continue with his
grabbing policy with King to be to where
we are going to sacrifice our piece in a
style with a four after King captors a2
and pawn captures b3y can pack his bag
and go home as this position is that
much little for the white camper if King
kept his b3 then the simplest day is
night to d4 checked and after King to be
to end the move Queen to b6 white King
will be checkmated very soon so that's
not a great choice for the white and
instead of capturing on b3 if White King
try to run away with King to be too well
that doesn't change the scenario as
after pawn captures c2 by force black is
going to check me why King a fluke to c1
the night to d4 is a very strong reply
so accordingly white has the only reply
left King kept to c2 after that you
already know blacks first reply yup it's
night to d4 check King to c1
what else and now the final moments guys
kindly pause the video and find out a
force
checkmate sequence
okay let's start the fast food is very
obvious rook to even check for sinking
to the be two square and now this
dazzling group sacrifice Queen to b6
check if King to c3 then Queen to b3 is
a checkmate and after King captures even
and the move rook to e8 check yes white
can put some pieces in between but that
doesn't stop us to check me too white
cake that's it guys
I think the continuation I have shown
are more than enough to play against
this tricky line Queen to d3 the only
thing you have to remember is when white
plays the move Knight to c3 just
sacrifice the d5 pawn and give the
options to divide in which variation he
wants to lose thank you for watching
this video feel free to like subscribe
and comment and I see you in my fourth
episode bye and take care